how's it going everybody it's Warren and
Avengers endgame has done the impossible
Avengers endgame has completely
shattered the box-office records before
Avengers and game came out it was
expected to not only be one of the
biggest Marvel movies of all time but
one of the biggest movies of all time in
general and so far that is exactly what
is happening Avengers in game earned an
A+ CinemaScore and currently sits at 96%
fresh on Rotten Tomatoes the movie
completely shatters the box-office
records
earning three hundred and fifty million
domestic and over 1.2 billion worldwide
for its opening and Avengers endgame
continues to break multiple records that
had the best Thursday night opening with
60 million the best first-day opening
with a hundred and fifty 6.7 million and
the best Saturday with a hundred and
nine million Avengers endgame was
predicted to earn somewhere between two
hundred and sixty million and three
hundred million but at three hundred and
fifty million it blew past the previous
record of two hundred and fifty seven
point seven million which was set last
year by Avengers infinity war it's
estimated that more than 30 million
Americans and more than 100 million
global guests experienced endgame on the
big screen in one weekend which is
insane Disney's chairman alan horne
credited Marvel Studios and of course
it's President Kevin Feige on Avengers
in games massive success Avengers in
game is the culmination of 22
interconnected MCU films and has
successfully wrapped them up it's sad to
see this era come to an end but it's
awesome to see that it is completely
crushing the box-office with predictions
that it could even hit two billion but
it does have some competition coming up
that could affect it such as Pokemon
detective Pikachu and John wick three
but let me know what you all think let
me know your predictions do you think
Avengers in game will hit two billion or
is that just too insane let me know your
thoughts in the comments down below also
a reminder about my giveaway I'm giving
away a life-sized Infinity Gauntlet and
a glow-in-the-dark painting of Fano spy
glow by boat you can also find more of
his work at globe I bowed comm I'll put
the link in the description down below
but if you want to enter for your chance
to win all you have to do is be
subscribed to my channel like this video
and comment down
below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero or villain as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
woof
[Music]
to your desperation to save the universe
you killed half of its population yeah
you did it very nice and dull it took
you said it cost you everything while
crying like a baby now your